and as you became more immersed in a
lifestyle of LA what were your
impressions you grew up in Connecticut
you were used to probably knowing a lot
of people around town la is different
there's so many interesting people what
were your impressions I think weren't
interesting I hated I hated it for the
first six months I hated it till I
started getting late I mean let's be
honest when I first got out there you
know I think the air quality was
terrible I didn't know anybody except
the three friends I came out with I
didn't have a job it just seemed
overwhelming a little bit because you
come out with a script and we don't know
anybody we don't know what we're doing
we hadn't quite come to that realization
the script was even finished yet so it
was just this first beginning of an
adventure and we had no idea what was
going to happen my initial plan was to
stay for six months I don't think I ever
told the guys that but I just kind of
said go my out six months it doesn't
work go back but obviously things change
because i think it's 11 years now hope
yours but at the time you know i didn't
like but once I started getting familiar
and kind of I got a job working at a
radio station I couldn't get a job there
was nothing when I first came out here
you know the whole concept was to live
this this dream to go after a dream and
the first thing I do is try to find the
same type of miserable job that I had
back east except it was just different
version of it one of the interviews I
went on was for a company called cintas
did he make uniforms for people and they
wouldn't hire me I had a good resume but
I think everyone could tell that I
wasn't enthusiastic I'm haven't come
3,000 miles to do the same I've
been doing back east why would I do that
it make any sense I think they could
tell so a girl I met along the way she
said to me what's the one thing that you
always loved doing it was only one thing
I never got paid for it was radio so I
kind of read
my interest radio at that point and
started working behind the scenes so
yeah once I had kind of a place you know
a job now and I started dating before I
had their jobs so for me I felt like a
bunk go out like her own what do you do
nothing right now I'm in transition I
didn't realize you know the whole thing
about la guys not working so I didn't
quite realize how bad that must have
sounded and how girls must have gone
home and told their girlfriends and
Kafka is that a pretty good job but so I
got a job and then in a spring of 2001 I
met a girl and so that kind of yeah I
got into a routine and suddenly you know
you got money coming in and you get laid
some guys 24 that what else you need any
booze maybe that got a roof over ya it
was it was fine you know I had reliable
transportation i get around started to
get into a lifestyle that's when it's
very getting better for me
you